die täter stehen ja meine sehr verehrten
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video bevor mit dem heutigen jolo sling
und ein bisschen spaß haben werden weil
ich noch kurzfristige von gestern gehen
da habe ich ein video partikel 13
gemacht und artikel 13 wurde gestern
abend leider doch in einen finalen
entwurf gegossene und es sieht danach
aus als würden wir uns in richtung von
upload filtern bewegen da gab es aber
sehr viele aufgebrachte antworten unter
anderem von bronk von story von regie
von junge und ich glaube da werden wir
als community noch einiges auf die beine
stellen und ich bin auch gerne bereit
dafür zu demonstrieren dafür auf die
straße zu gehen kleine pizza aber jetzt
leute widmen wir uns der spaßigen seite
des lebens zumindest für einen kurzen
moment denn ich hab von einer
zuschauerin ein video auf instagram
zugeschickt bekommen wo man sich
wirklich fragt ob das echt sein kann
aber es ist echt das ist gab es wirklich
zwar ist das video das die tamina 1993
und ich habe schon mal kurz reingeschaut
und ihr werdet mir nicht glauben worum
es bei dem dieter sowie da geht das
bekannte tagungshaus der automat
stiftung in der nähe teams diese männer
haben sich nicht zum zeitvertreib
versammelt sie haben ein gemeinsames
problem ihr vorname ist dieter aber dass
gerade richtig gehört ihr gemeinsames
problem ist dass ihr vorname dieter ist
und deswegen haben die sich in einer
therapiegruppe zusammengefunden
ja funktionieren meine ordnung wirklich
das gerade wirklich gesagt worden
das kann eigentlich nicht sein hören wir
doch mal rein diese männer haben sich
nicht zum zeitvertreib versammelt sie
haben ein gemeinsames problem ihr
vorname ist dieter ich dachte jetzt
schon über das wirkliche problem ist so
keine ahnung sie haben alle nur ein bein
oder sie wurden alle in ihrer schulzeit
gemobbt oder sie sind alle farbenblind
aber sie heißen alle dieter was sie
leiden darunter
ausgenommen dieser mann er heißt arthur
und ist deutschlands einziger pre
nominal therapeut ok artur raus raus das
ist eine dieser runde hier okay oli
dieter sell out aber ganz kurz was was
war seine berufsbezeichnung nominal
therapeut er heißt a tor und ist
deutschlands einziger pre nominal
therapeut ich nehme an premium
widerhallt therapeut ist die laziali
sierte form von vornamen therapeut also
er therapiert menschen wegen ihres
vornamens
ich würde sagen deutschland 2009 10 aber
es ist nicht deutschland 2009/10 dass es
deutschland 1993 vor 26 jahren gab es
schon so eine mumie die kacke alter oder
heißt das was das würde in der hilfen
erfolgen
ich weiß natürlich dieter es heißt gern
natürlich
also leute ich will nicht unsensibel
erscheinen aber was ist daran so schlimm
dass man dieser heißt es ist ein grund
dass man sich in einer therapiegruppe
irgendwo auf dem land zusammen findet
das sage ich seit jeweils eine woche
dauern die vornamens therapeutischen
gruppen seminare in denen menschen die
sich durch ihren vornamen in ihrer
seelischen entwicklung gestört fühlen
super das würde ich auch sagen wer auch
meine erste reaktion auf jeden fall wenn
wir irgendwann sagt sebastian weißt du
was ich fühle mich mit meinem vornamen
einfach nicht so wohl ich heiße
vanilleeis müller und ich hatte immer
wegen man das von uns gehänselt verwehrt
hat bin ich der erste tipp der person
geben würde erstmal sich hinzustellen
und abwechselnd gegen bedingten konnte
rechten schuh zuschlag in münchen die
sich durch ihren vornamen in ihrer
seelischen ganz klar also ich muss sagen
ich bin jetzt hier nicht als experte auf
diesem gebiet unterwegs aber dann hilft
es bei psychischen problemen wenn man
sich gegen die physische liegt ach du
bist mit deinem vornamen unzufrieden
kevin schlag dir einfach kurz gegen die
füße dann geht es wieder jeweils eine
woche dauern die vornamens
therapeutischen gruppen seminare in
denen menschen psychologische hilfe
erhalten
es hat echt mehr
das gab es wirklich in deutschland also
ich muss sagen ich stecke jetzt auch
nicht ganz drin an der zeit also ich
weiß nicht genau was 1993 passiert ist
ob es da irgendwie so eine große die
tabelle durch deutschland ging aber
denken wir an heutige zeiten heute kevin
würde ich sagen ist ein name als ich dir
jetzt kein kämen treten aber manche
leute benutzers als kleine kevin also
sind bestimmt einige kevins da draußen
die sich dieses video anschauen in
meinem bekanntenkreis noch einige ich
glaube keiner von denen ist bisher auf
die idee gekommen deswegen in eine
therapiegruppe zu gehen wodurch aber
werden ausgerechnet bei männern mit dem
vornamen psychische schädigungen
ausgelöst
was hans apel dippel dippel doppelt
appell sippel dipl doppel sehr
effektiver zauberspruch weil man
aufgrund seines vornamens diskriminiert
wird denkt daran wie ich in der schule
zuerst den buchstaben d kennenlernte der
dicke pitter drückt den dom gitter durch
den dicken dreck das kann nicht ernst
sein als ob man in der schule den
buchstaben die komplette dass der dicke
pitter dem dummen dieter durch den
dicken dreck drückt was ist überhaupt
dicker dreck kann mir jemand sagen was
dicker dreck ist das war so die erste
assoziation die ich bekam dieter stand
für sag ich mal etwas schlichtes
proletarische system im plus das lässt
sich als art von natürlich leicht sagen
du wir beide
wir wissen gar nicht was bedeutet dieser
zu heißen positiv zu entwickeln ist auch
der klang eines vornamens dazu bietet
jetzt kowski schröder spezielle übung
unter freiem himmel an
was kommt jetzt mit absurder scheider
wieso wird wenn jetzt auch draußen
geschleppt
wieso ganz ehrlich der titel für dieses
video wäre einfach wie sowieso dies wie
sie das wieso braucht man stark knie um
im namen aussprechen zu können
[Gelächter]
die tat sei die tat nicht stark genug in
den knien
dieter letztes kita die täter stehen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jetzt ganz dieter stehen es stehe ein
bisschen mehr die täter einfach du musst
einfach einfach mehr im etat stehen
bisschen mehr dieter in deine entstand
anbringen das jetzt zum beispiel auch
dieter geht es auch so gut was ich da
[Musik]
auf dieser welt halter aber dass wir uns
gerade im gehört er überträgt hat sehr
viel kraft
ja also macht das video lieber nichts
laut bei euch zu hause ist könnte sein
dass die ein oder andere sicherung raus
fliegt wisst ihr dass meine stimme
gerade jetzt sehen wir zusammen fast
kenne dieses kind kennt die klobigen zu
disneyland
das finde ich einfach warum machst du so
was von vers zu sein vorname oder nicht
akzeptierte phone hat natürlich auch
enorm ausflügen aufs privatleben okay
meint jetzt gerade
egal ob die leute ja es gibt solche und
solche menschen es gibt menschen die den
sowas weiß egal die können adolf kevin
heißen doch was macht den im ganzen
leben lang im ausland gibt empfindliche
menschen also man kann nicht alle
menschen einen kamm scheren wenn manche
leute dass wir die richtige lösung
halten diese szene gar nie aus dem kampf
um ihren wald stehen
gauleiter das will ich noch mal sehen
die da die
und so weit dass wir jetzt endlich
sterben meine damalige freundin jetzige
frau gebeten habe wir haben noch nicht
mehr mit meinem vorhaben uns diese
anzusprechen
mega alter 1 verpasst sich da gerade
irgendwas so ich schaue dieses video an
die überhaupt keine ahnung woher dieser
dieter hast kommt das ist so schlimm
daran die dazu heißen also ja es ist
nicht der schönste vorname wie
vielleicht leonardo aber sein könnte
heißt er hans-dieter warum sagt man ja
vornehmlich noch ans wobei nämlich
eigentlich die beiden täter seminar
gehen der familie partnerschaftlichen
beziehung mann und frau
man gibt mal eben den zucker fakih was
reichlich zucker geben sich die täter
seminaristen übrigens auch während
solcher interaktiver selbstverlust
prozesse ja ok aber was hat dieter was
hat das dieter seminar mit schwul sein
zutun keine frage am rande so ich kann
natürlich bisher diesem ganzen view
komplett folgen kann alles selber
nachvollziehen was in diesem video
geschehen ist aber das war jetzt so die
erste frage in diesem video die sich mir
gestellt hat wo ich nicht ganz glauben
konnte nicht auch noch zum opfer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da bleiben sichtbarer heilungserfolge
nicht aus dieser dieter hat es geschafft
in dieser liga alles geschafft dieser
dieter hat es geschafft was hat er
geschafft leute was soll man dazu sagen
also ich würde mal sagen jeder der
dieses video gerade sieht der dass hier
gerade hört und sebastian heißt zeigt
euch in den kommentaren steht zu ihrem
vornamen
wir können es zusammen schaffen ja nach
diesem wunderbaren lehrvideo leute kann
ich euch hier drüben noch ein weiteres
von mir vorgeschlagen das video für euch
empfehlen checkt das ab und falls ihr
auch mit eurem von haben sich zufrieden
sein solltet bedenkt immer
möglicherweise habt ihr einfach nicht
genug energie in den knien